look I don't have my own kids I have
nieces that I'm very very close with my
brother's daughters and the idea that
anyone in our family would be abusive to
these kids if one of them legitimately
like identified as transgender is
ridiculous and I think my brother and
sister-in-law should have the right as
parents to be able to be there for their
daughters if one of them is going
through something like that you know
what I'm saying it's just like this
preemptive notion that the parents are
going to be awful
I agree with that and remember you can
go into these public schools and it'll
be like don't tell your parents they'll
freak out there is an assumption that's
at the front of it I agree with you 100%
I want you to look at this chart Tom us
sex reassignment surgery Market markets
if you guys are looking for great
investment this fantastic serious
serious fantastic investment Michael bur
over here